alright shall we go to the Internet ok
what do you think about President
Obama's recent off-mike comments I heard
them the other day yes regarding the
gops negotiating strategy I wish I wish
he would sound like that when he was on
mic
what yes when I would well his remarks
which she made many comments that he
didn't think we're getting picked up are
pretty much the same remarks he made in
his speech that day I mean he's doing it
in a colloquial way but basically what
he's saying is the same fight that you
guys had here which is one don't tell me
Republicans that after voting for huge
deficits and the war in tax cuts that
you're gonna school me on deficit
spending right which is what he said so
stop that and that number two I I don't
fold as easily as people think you did
and when that CBO number came out the
other day that said actually remember
that the number was really only three
hundred fifty three million not thirty
eight billion now who looks who got the
better deal right so I think for for the
liberal base and even for others he
looks like this is a guy who's I wonder
if he knows when he that he's really on
it's gonna get picked up you think there
might be some of that in it because the
campaign has begun after all that's true
and he has announced less yes you know
he's officially a carry on but remember
the other time he get caught caught on
tape I don't think he wanted that to
happen when he said big the guns and
that people cling to their guns and
Bibles and by the way he was way off on
that yeah
okay John said of us some of us cling to
our currents and our Bibles John asks is
it is a fine reason or it is a fine a
reasonable penalty for someone like Kobe
Bryant says [ __ ] when you want to cut off
his finger
I mean $100,000 that's a you know that's
a pretty stiff fine for saying one
inappropriate word yeah but you know
again it's it freedom of speech you know
you can say these things but you know
the question is what the final thousand
dollars should be doing something more
proactive right you go and you know if
you're forced to community service in
some way shape or form so why why not do
something like that service NBA is
trying to be in the image business a
little bit here don't - let it go would
be condoning it they've got some social
standards so you want their players drop
hold - yeah that's it he has to do
something about have to be service like
looking at the bar be like can do
service like going and saying it's a bad
thing to say that about me it beats the
hell out of being on trial can we just
say this is gonna be no the NBA could
lose both its gay fans no it's not a
kind of word guy I agree but you know I
don't know and also why did he buy his
wife a ring uh just out of habit I guess
but it whenever he [ __ ] up he buys his
wife a ring okay well any of you going
to be going to see the Ayn Rand Atlas
Shrugged movie no I couldn't I mean I
couldn't get through the book although
yeah the book was yeah I I mean I talked
I quoted some alan greenspan talking
about a paul ryan big and ran fan newt
and huge yeah kind of
it doesn't match up with the Catholic
faith though does it well an ren was an
atheist yeah it's kind of a yeah yeah
it's all in the interpretation well
where is this interpretation that is
being on paper it's pretty extreme I
have never been able to get through and
read I've tried and you know there are
people and some of intelligent people
who you know are big big fans of Ayn
Rand but I I did they made a great movie
about an Ren
like 10 15 years ago with Helen Mirren
playing and Rand and I think it was Eric
Stoltz playing the acolyte a falls in
love and Peter Fonda is her husband and
at the end he is a grey line he says I
never know what any of it was about and
I think you know for a lot of people
that's what it is would you be in favor
of removing the cap on social security
contributions in order to make it more
solvent yep removing the cap - what -
just unlimited let me just take the cap
like the cap all you know is it Medicare
my Medicare contributions are unlimited
so if I found that out when I went to my
accountant this year I was like wow
what's all this money going to I said
well that's Medicare it's like whatever
you make it's like 1.5 yes Social
Security stops at a certain point so
just continues right right if you make
ten billion dollars you pay 1.5 percent
I mean I'm sure they'll find ways out of
it I saw it I saw it in the paper today
the richest 400 people in this country
paid 16.6%
federal taxes the average American 22.5
there's some Republicans like it is
something very wrong but you know the
other interesting that David Lane harder
writes for New York Times had a great
number about this - though the number
that the amount of money that people put
into Medicare right through their taxes
yeah is twice it's a lot smaller than
what they're gonna get out of it right
so if you the average person puts
$150,000 in over the course of their
working life they get three hundred
forty thousand dollars worth of health
care that's a pretty good deal yeah so
but Social Security has to be tokay
ekeus I says what do you think about the
Donald and his words about his
relationship with the blacks Michael
you're here one of the black
oh I thought about it I could just okay
the only thing I guess is I'm just glad
to be with the white right that night
it's one of those nights right we got
the brown the Browns you got the you
know inaudible Benetton out of a show
it's an anachronistic isn't an a stand
asinine but in an act anachronistic
right it's really there it's it's like
really out of out of right context it's
like wedding jitters too so it can be
bipartisan it's sort of like when Joe
Biden yeah had that horrible comment
about Obama that he's articulately
stereotyped yeah and it says what
grandpa says the blacks the blacks a
great relationship with the blacks it's
gigantic ly stupid and this guy wants to
be President and that's his racial
sensitivity I mean here's Joe Johnson
over here here's Charlie Smith over here
but because they're black he's gonna
judge him the same the broad brushing is
very dangerous and oh it is yeah and
he's got a what's really an out of this
what's really well at first I don't
think he's gonna get at it but he's
leading yeah you know but he also this
week I saw is trying to curry favor with
religious people now Donald Trump does
not seem to me like the kind of guy who
goes to church but he said I'm a Sunday
church go well he said usually tries to
go on a Sunday he went he stirred my
love that Jesus is huge
huge I am the best at worshiping God I
am the best of anybody gotta go all
right Thank You panel ratified you thank
you audience
[Applause]